herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
eintrag als persönlicher corp wie
erkennt der hintergrund ist nicht mein
untergrund sondern ich bin bei sturm in
den büros weil wir hier im hause sturm
waffe wird erstmal noch das schlamassel
von gestern bereinigt als auch sturm wie
mein heutiger gast bin sehr sehr
gespannt ich hatte bisher anspruchsvolle
und weniger anspruchsvolle gäste aber
ich bin mir sicher dass es heute noch
eine ganz besondere herausforderung wird
bei sturm das muss eigentlich jeder von
euch wissen dass selbst koch youtube das
heißt nicht dass ich einer bin oder den
anspruch habe aber stimmig zum richtiger
so du bist so ein richtiger du bist erst
youtuber und dann nicht kaufen sondern
jemand der kocht aber du machst ist
schon gemacht ist schon ganz gut deshalb
denke ich mal fast auch schon viele
viele leckere sachen gegessen meine
aufgabe wird sein ich hörte zu
überzeugen
breast cancer dia heißt das stichwort
mir heute morgen zwar hat mir einfach
nur gesagt ich habe mir gedacht ich will
den mann überzeugen wir machen nicht
früher wir machen dreck das kind
verliert mit aber kauft mit tomate mit
sour cream so gemacht das ist so und
nebenbei als teilzeit müssen das
reinigen rät einfach stunde wieder im
hintergrund versucht irgendwie so zu tun
dass wir das heute so gerne zuerst auch
mal werden die hier organisiert spaß
sind so krank organisiert diese kamera
die ich hier benutze gehört nicht mir
sondern sie ist einfach da sie ist
geladen und es ist einfach nur ein
wunder
ich habe größten respekt dafür
ich musste gerade eben ein ersatzakku
weil sebastian bach meine akkus alle
lehrer sind käfern und zu essen die eier
schnell liebe diese seite steuern auch
eine sehr coole sind aber das sei es ist
schon krass
die eier sind verkehrt private private
bist du bereit ich bin bereit wo man
dort zeigt mir damit aufschneiden ja
damit kehren haus auf anfang und dann so
ein bisschen an dreht und hier kannst du
dann in die schale geben und dann so
stückchen ausmachen
die jetzt probiert oh mein gott oh mein
gott
jetzt im sommer gesagt passt perfekt ins
streifen und dann hat's oma in georgia
sketchen dessen flex also das fürchten
flex kritisierte die machen wie gesagt
auch käse schreiben in die kiste bier
dann zuerst natürlich auch nach
eigentlich hätte ich gelegenen these
kaufen können aber ich finde irgendwie
geriebener käse ist würdelos wenn es das
auch ich finde geriebener käse ist
würdelos sagt er während er gerade in
den kaffee aus sondermaschine th
portieren aber wirklich kalte milch da
in der exklusiven tag das ist irgendwie
schwer also meine mama und mein leben
lang eingeprügelt dass man parmesan
frisch sein muss was er noch mal das
andere sie aber irgendwie hat sich das
auf jeder art von käse wie man die
riesen konsumieren kann transformiert
das schwein wir erwarten planen
schreiben ich habe überhaupt keine neues
geöffnet wir machen diesen dingen an das
ist ist das eine bake
das ist ein brett einfach aber das werde
ich erst mal zu einer machen lassen
leichter dafür dass es das video mit der
schlechtesten soundqualität ist was er
jemals stories küche gefunden habt ihr
mit anstecken - ich habe sogar ein
mikrofon offizieren mein handy als
absicherung der brauchen wir legen jetzt
mal den bacon hier drüben in die pfannen
ein staat das lied man nicht mehr auf
der besten kamera und po ist es nicht
sehr happy ist es noch nicht so schnell
wie wir
entweder er freunde wirklich ist das ein
traum kann hierüber geht und nach
einfach die seriösesten sachen an
equipment verfügen wird auf langsam
heißt aber ihr seht es vielleicht die
pfanne ist ein bisschen angesetzt ich
hoffe das wird kein problem sein leben
jetzt ein bisschen von dem rohen ei in
die pfanne hinein war doch ein bisschen
viel aber das teure situation dann käse
hinein
jetzt kommt der kommt auf diese mischung
ein paar tor auf doch einfach ein
bisschen an drückend das dann kontakt
ist auf jeden fall werde der verkehr
muss greifen und dann will ich das ganze
gleicht ihr werdet sehen in einer
drehung wenden
ja es verbindet sich geladen habe ich
merk schlug das ist so ein bisschen
gefühlssache so den richtigen zeitpunkt
erwischen
das ganze dann einmal zu drehen wie
gesagt noch dauert jetzt einmal den
versuch ich helfen ein bisschen nach
chur und habe es gesehen leute das hat
halbwegs gut funktioniere das früher
erklärt dran kann jetzt auch von beiden
seiten ein bisschen crispy machen das
legen wir den speck marinen den christa
wir hinein in die kita gehen als würde
ich meine spanien und jetzt nehmen wir
einfach die käser dir und klappen sie
hier so zu und ich werde das ganze noch
so ein bisschen flach drücken weil das
hebt sich sonst anlegt dass du drauf und
wir warten wie gesagt ein bisschen dass
das von beiden seiten ein bisschen an
bäumen okay jetzt holen wir die kiste
die heraus war es ist sehr heiß und es
schon wieder der welt braucht bekommt
bundes johanna die bringt und ich
schneide jetzt so in dreiecke dafür
möchte ich dieses scharfe messer mal
probieren 13 ich muss ja stimmen
überzeugen das ist ja kein
strafverfahren ein tag persönlicher kopf
von verschiedenen youtube waren heute
von firmen und ich habe mich sehr gute
noten bekommen gemacht haben oh mein
gott kann man nicht buchen
nur wenn du berühmt bist leider käse und
eisen drin wir legen wieder den portier
auch aus irgendeinem grund ist er viel
kleiner als der andere aber es ist sehr
gut vielleicht wird das jetzt auch sturm
ist verschwörungs musste die schönste
sein
wir wenden das ganze schön sauce aus den
let's go home speck rein hier noch
bisschen sour cream einstreichen
wer das ganze wieder zu wenn ihr das
seht und ist zuhause namen machen wollt
das wichtigste daran ist die
beschichtete pfanne weil sonst
funktioniert das mit dem dreh nicht und
wird das ein riesiges schlamassel
benutzt eine beschichtete pfanne
dann kann es eigentlich nur funktioniert
das essen steht ich würde sagen ich bin
ich jetzt mal zum tisch freddy und dann
geht's los
du weißt aber halt im hinterkopf bernd
du sparst du wirst heute jede mahlzeit
mit 1 bis 10 punkten bewerten müssen
also gut jetzt auf jeden fall 10 bis 19
uhr könnt ihr immer noch besser werden
falls die schmecken
das habe ich so in irgendwelchen
amerikanischen flut videos gesehen war
mode drauf das für mich ist eine
klassische neun von zehn im klassischen
neuen funktion bei es könnte besser sein
bestimmt aber es ist halt übertrieben
aber ich kann ja keine 10.50 ergeben
dass geht er nicht funktionierten ist
eigentlich dafür auch erst auf essen.de
ist wirklich sehr lecker ich geb dir
sagen wir sehen uns für das finale
rating wenn wir aufgegessen nähe von
gent wir uns gleich wieder damit für
mich noch mal neu sehen sein kann
neun von zehn leute dann sehen wir für
mittagessen und damit ist es zeit fürs
mittagessen sturm hat sich was relativ
einfach ist von mir gewünscht steak mit
kartoffeln und weil stimme überzeugen
wenn man die kartoffeln die ich schon
für sandra gemacht habe also quasi diese
offen röstkartoffeln und dazu habe ich
für mich ein sehr nice day geholt das
ist ein trikot und lehmann sagt unsere
coach das habe ich schon mal frisch
gebackene video und erläutern wird
ich muss anfangen die richtig kartoffeln
scheider wir können wir auch liebend
gern noch mal eure vorschläge in die
kommentare schreiben
wer dabei sein soll ich habe ganz oft
schon christoph gelesen dass wir
natürlich cool ich habe mit rock nicht
so super viel zu tun ich kenne ihn aber
wir haben es lange nicht gesehen weiß
gar nicht wann das letzte mal was ich
gesehen habe dann ist es immer so ein
bisschen ein bisschen schwer sind
sozusagen ende drehen und halt man sonst
gar nicht so viel miteinander zu tun hat
das wäre cool luca wollen alle sehen
kommt auf jeden fall noch bock das
langfristig vielleicht nicht auch mal
mit irgendwie leute zu machen die nicht
von youtube unbedingt kommt übrigens
sehr lustig dadurch dass wir jetzt quasi
zum ersten mal so richtig regelmäßig
beim kochen zählt sicherlich für lustige
gesichter machen so zum beispiel wenn
ich kartoffeln schälen sei denn man kann
nicht ordentlich ps an
einen großen teelöffel backpulver und
wie auch schon beim letzten mal machen
wir ein kleines knoblauch rosmarin öl
das gebe ich jetzt einfach mal in den
top hinein und wollen wie du willst was
abgeht betont verdoppeln
zum öl die kartoffeln sollen quasi wie
so ein bisschen kartoffelbrei um sich
herum jetzt wollen wir den ofen auf der
iss vorgeheizt und geben ein motiv
kartoffeln hinein
ich sagte also müssen wirklich gut
voneinander getrennt sein
das ist glaube ich einen 700 gramm stück
habe ich jetzt ein bisschen schon auf
raumtemperatur kommen lassen also das
ist schon zwei stunden oder so was
draußen und das bett einmal in der mitte
regieren
das macht überhaupt nichts mit chakuza
stimmt vielleicht 40 euro um stunden zu
überzeugt schön in der mitte können wir
zwar schöne stücke fleisch und ich habe
wieder meine grillplatte mitgebracht
auch der werde ich die beiden stakes
vielleicht zu bereiten das ganze jetzt
braucht man auch in der zeit wenn die
kartoffeln fertig alles ist
wir sind draußen am grill hier sind die
beiden schönen stakes auf dem
wunderschönen waffe brett ich habe extra
die geriffelte seite von der platte nach
oben gelegt dass ein schönes muster
haben auf dem stick auch eine minute pro
seite
das dritte mal in folge
und dann hatte ich noch ein bisschen
ziehen ich würde sagen dann sehen wir
uns vielleicht gleich sogar einfach
schon wenn das essen auf dem teller ist
was uns als mittagessen probieren was
das jetzt genau macht das ist ein es ist
ein ort bemüht gemeinsam mit knoblauch
rosmarin kartoffeln
das ist hier aus bombay medium gewünscht
sportordnung hat er genug um mein gott
ich muss jetzt auch ja neu 14
das gab jetzt fühle ich mich richtig
sonst kann ich gleich einfach so in das
fitnessstudio und wirklich gut aber es
ist wirklich und kartoffeln passen auch
sehr guter zone mit dem knoblauch
ich kann auch bewertung
sturm ich möchte heute abend bolognese
essen das klingt erstmal ganz okay kann
ja nicht so schwer sein die sache ist
sturm ist polonaise könig ich muss mir
was einfallen lassen ich habe jetzt hier
gerade zwei krawatten bisschen sellerie
eine mittlere zwiebel und werde das
alles erst mal fein würfeln
hier gehe ich schon ein bisschen
olivenöl in die fahne dann mit bisschen
weil ich natürlich auch ganz ordentlich
leben willst macht es hier einfach schon
mal an wie gesagt hier einzuwirken
astana sturm ihr habt schon in allen
varianten glaube ich überall lese
gemacht und mache das ganze
wahrscheinlich um mich wirklich zu
testen ob ich hab' ich konkurrenzfähig
bin
dieses komme ein tag als persönlicher
koch sind eigentlich jedes mal drei
videos in einem
der mann drei sachen und es geht relativ
wenig leute glaube ich die das machen
ich bin umso glücklicher dass die erste
folge so gut ankam dieser topf wird so
schnell heißt wir gehen jetzt auf jeden
fall in den top 4 unser hackfleisch
hinein und warten dass einer von beiden
seiten an das jetzt übrigens einfach
rind und schwein für mich so dass bleibt
es jetzt von beiden seiten schön angebot
sowie das gesamte fleisch noch mal raus
und jetzt in diesen topf das gewürfelte
gemüse hinein das ganze schon jetzt
wiederum mit weißwein ab
und warten bis hier ein bisschen
verkauft nur wenn mal die kamera von
hier oben bei mir ist gesagt im grunde
so hier ist das ganze schöne kirche der
weißwein verkauft gerade ein bisschen
drüben liegt das fleisch vorbereitet und
ich merke schon richtig schalla 3
und dann kommt noch hühnerbrühe hinein
ich habe das keine lust die vor zu
mission und ich mache ein thema für ihn
ein und schütteten einfach das wasser
war 250 milliliter und verpassen so
jetzt ist hier jede menge flüssigkeit
drin
würde das ganze mal aber die nervös ich
vernünftig auflösen kann
so wird das ganze reduziert geben wir
auch einfach schon die tomaten dazu
gebrochene 400 gramm tomaten sauce
bolognese ist eigentlich eine fleischlos
und keine tomaten so ist also für uns
klingt haben wir 800 gramm fleisch von
400 gramm tomaten die gms dazu verrühren
das ganze noch mal und jetzt gehen wir
zu dem ganzen das fleisch wird ihr wisst
schon an der rebe kassel es ist locker
eine stunde später und die soße ist sehr
stark reduziert sieht sehr sehr nice aus
hoffeld
ich würde für die mich hier überzeugen
können nein für ihn nicht überzeugen die
leute darin kommt was er jetzt auch so
lange möchte hier noch vor sich hin
könnte sie erst mal abschmecken dann
sehen wir es gleich am platz wieder nach
durch gerade wunderbar der sound ist ja
das habe ich mich auch gewundert als ich
das video geschnitten habe irgendwie es
bei diesem clip hier kein ton
aufgenommen worden aber das kein problem
ich vertonen einfach für euch hast du
mich ja schon walking gut du musst jetzt
müll essen einfach es nun für schuhe
ach ja ok keine ahnung was das gerade
war was hat zu lange gedauert uns nicht
einfach drin zu lassen
sie haben dann auf jeden fall gegessen
und ich habe schon gesagt dass sie mir
noch kein feedback geben soll bis wir
komplett aufgegessen haben
du hast die letzten 15 minuten kein bock
gesportelt ich durfte nicht bedurfte es
nicht
die was es war ein erlebnis war eine
reihe sind nur sagen ich bin aber so was
er eigentlich weit
deswegen muss ich leider sagen es war
sehr lecker aber das kann für mich nur
und das wissen die leute die mich kennen
ein ja so 88 prozent sein
das ist aber das von dir zu hören als es
dann weißt du warum sagst du besuchst
ich bin noch schwabe durch deutschland
ich brauche alles immer ertränkt in
soest meinte spaghetti bolognese da
liegt dann sicher nur noch so ein rudel
deckel herausragend bei dir ist es so
wie eine wohnung lesen sein sollte und
da bin ich halt dann so weit weg
verstehen aber wenn ich mir jetzt noch
so sendet dann ja nicht einmal kontakt
da ist mal ganz viel wasser trinkt ich
weiß aber das hast du nicht hingestellt
dann sagen okay also trotzdem super
heftige bewertung von bolognese könig
oder dem bus oder diese fonds polo groß
eine eine sache muss und dass ich bin
auf jeden fall sehr zufrieden und sehr
fertig mache diesem tag an dem ich
befriedige tochter aber es war mir eine
große freude
ich würde sagen wir sehen uns beim
nächsten video beziehungsweise bei der
nächsten folge einfach persönlicher koch
wieder macht es gut bis dahin oder an
für chaos gebe stunden dicht ist
[Musik]